THE CONVERSATION STARTS HERE
TONIGHT.
THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME IS KELLYANNE CONWAY.
THIS IS KIND OF A TALE OF TWO
ELECTIONS MADE CLEAR TONIGHT.
FOX CALLED ARIZONA FOR KATIE
HOBBS WHO REFUSE TO DEBATE IN
THAT RACE FOR GOVERNOR.
YET, THE GOP IS FLIPPING SEATS.
I GOT BACK FROM CALIFORNIA,
FLIPPING SEATS THERE.
WHAT'S YOUR READ RIGHT NOW
TONIGHT?
>> FEW THINGS, LOT HAS BEEN SAID
IN THE LAST WEEK.
ONE THING THAT HASN'T BEEN SAID
IS SOMETHING WE KNOW ABOUT
VOTERS.
WHICH IS WHEN THERE IS CHAOS AND
CRISES IN THE GROCERY BASKET AT
THE GAS PUMP, IN UKRAINE AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER IN OUR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE OF RISE IN
CRIME, PEOPLE HAVE TWO CHOICES.
THEY CAN THROW THEM ALL OUT OR
START OVER OR THEY SAY THERE'S
SO MUCH CRISES AND INCERTAINTY,
I CAN'T INVITE IT MORE IN OUR
LIVES.
WE DID A PROJECT WITH BIDEN
DISENGAGERS.
THOSE ARE PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE
FOR HIM.
THEY ARE SWING VOTERS.
THE INDEPENDENT ENDED UP
BREAKING FOR DEMOCRATS.
THE TREND OF GOING FOR THE PARTY
OUT OF POWER BY DOUBLE DIGITS.
THE BIDEN ENGAGERS THEY WERE
CONVINCED DEMOCRATS DIDN'T HAVE
WHAT IT TOOK.
IN THE HOUSE, KEVIN McCARTHY
DID THE COMMITMENT TO AMERICA.
>> Laura: I JUMPED THERE.
I FOUND IT VERY GENERAL.
I FOUND IT WAS LIKE A LOT OF
HEADLINES.
THERE WAS NO MEAT ON THOSE
BONES.
>> IT'S 500 WORDS FRONT AND
BACK.
IT GAVE PEOPLE SOMETHING OTHER
THAN YOU JUST NOT AGAINST THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> Laura: REALLY?
>> SORRY, WE'RE GOING TO GET THE
HOUSE AND WE FLIPPED SEATS IN
NEW JERSEY, OREGON, NEW YORK.
>> THE HOUSE DIDN'T DO ENOUGH.
THEY ARE GOING TO GET THE
MAJORITY.
THIS IS SOMETHING WHERE THEY
GAINED SEATS IN 2020.
YOU DON'T SEE THE KIND OF WAR
WITH THE REPUBLICAN VOTER IN THE
HOUSE THAT YOU SEE IN THE
SENATE.
SENATE LEADERSHIP CLEARLY JUST
DISDAINED REPUBLICAN VOTERS.
THEY ARE BLAMING THEM FOR THEIR
FAILURES TO SECURE SOME OF THESE
VICTORIES.
THEY OFFERED NOTHING AS YOU
POINTED OUT OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
NO RESISTANCE TO THE BIDEN
AGENDA, NO VISION.
UNLIKE KEVIN McCARTHY.
MITCH McCONNELL SAID YOU
DIDN'T NEED TO HAVE A PLAN.
IT WAS SUFFICIENT THAT JOE BIDEN
WAS BAD.
THIS IS A MAN WHO WENT TO WAR
AGAINST THE TEA PARTY.
MANY OF THE PROBLEMS WE'RE
DEALING ARE HIS WAR AGAINST THE
VOTER FOR REPUBLICAN PARTY TO
THRIVE, IT NEEDS TO BE UNIFIED.
YOU NEED TO HAVE THE
ESTABLISHMENT AND THE VOTERS.
THEY SHOULD BE PROVIDING
CANDIDATES WHO VOTE PEOPLE LIKE.
THEY SHOULD BE TRYING TO INSTEAD
OF SABOTAGE, MITCH McCONNELL
SABOTAGED BLAKE MASTERS WHO CAME
CLOSE TO WINNING.
HE GAVE NO MONEY.
>> Laura: HE WAS SUPPORTING
CHUCK MORRIS IN NEW HAMPSHIRE
BEFORE BOLDUC.
IT WAS TOUGH.
McCARTHY TRIED TO PUT A
BLUEPRINT OUT THERE.
THEY WERE ALMOST -- THEY WEREN'T
IN SYNC.
THE VOTERS WERE JUMP IN HERE, I
THOUGHT THEY WERE NOT GETTING A
MESSAGE FROM THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
THAT WAS UNIFIED.
THE DEMOCRATS WERE PRETTY
UNIFIED.
>> POLLING SHOWS THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE FOR MOST VOTERS OF THE THE
ECONOMY.
VOTERS TRUST REPUBLICANS BY
DOUBLE DIGITS ON THE ECONOMY.
REPUBLICAN POLITICIANS FAILED TO
CLOSEST THE DEAL WITH THEM.
THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM.
IN TERMS OF MITCH McCONNELL
YOU CAN BRING A MESSAGE TO THE
TABLE OR YOU CAN BRING BRILLIANT
BACKGROUND POLICY, PROCEDURES.
WHICH IS WHAT MITCH McCONNELL
HAS BEEN CELEBRATED FOR.
THIS IS MASSIVE FAILURE.
HE'S BEEN IN LEADERSHIP FOR 20
YEARS.
HE'S BEEN THE LEADER FOR 16, 17
AT SOME POINT, WHAT DOES
SOMEBODY AROUND HERE HAVE TO DO
TO GET FIRED?
>> Laura: WE TALKED ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY A LOT IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
WE GOT TO HAVE METRICS.
HE DID GREAT JOB KEEPING MERRICK
GARLAND OFF THAT SUPREME COURT.
I WILL BE GRATEFUL FOR MITCH
McCONNELL.
>> CHUCK SCHUMER HAS THAT SAME
RECORD.
THEY GET MORE THAN JUST JUDGES
WITH CHUCK SCHUMER.
THEY GET A WHOLE AGENDA.
THEY GET VICTORY.
>> Laura: HE GOES ON TV AND
HE'LL ARGUE THE POINT.
SPEAKING OF KELLEY ANNE.
SENATOR SCHUMER HAD SO CALLED
ADVICE FOR GOP LEADERSHIP.
>> THE ANSWER IS FOR THE
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP, THOSE
NON-MAGA ONES TO BREAK WITH THE
MAGA PARTY AND WORK WITH YOU.
AMERICA WILL BREATHE SIGH OF
RELIEF.
THEY LIKED IT THIS SUMMER.
WE NEED TO DO MORE.
I'M WILLING TO REACH OUT.
>> WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR HIS
ADVICE.
ONE POISONOUS WORD THAT I
THOUGHT DONALD TRUMP DONE WITH
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
ELECTABILITY.
IT IS A FICTION.
VOTERS DON'T ASK WHO CAN WIN.
VOTERS ASK WHO THEY CAN LEAD.
MITCH McCONNELL SAID IN
AUGUST, I HAVE GREAT CONFIDENCE
IN OZ.
HE WAS ENDORSED BY TRUMP IN
APRIL.
COME NOVEMBER, WE SUPPOSED TO GO
BACK A YEAR AND SAY, OH MY GOD,
HE SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN THE
CANDIDATE.
ONCE THE VOTERS SPEAK, YOU HAVE
TO DO ALL YOU CAN TO SUPPORT
THEM FINANCIALLY, MESSAGE WISE
TACTICS.
I CAN FEEL -- I'M A
SELF-RESPECTING REPUBLICAN AND
CONSERVATIVE.
WE DIDN'T GO LIE AND SCARE THE
VOTERS.
THEY DIDN'T TALK ABOUT INFLATION
AND CRIME.
THEY HAVE NO GOOD MESSAGE.
THEY ON A SUGAR HIGH, THE
POLITICAL ONE NIGHT STAND WITH
OBAMA AND HILLARY AND SAYING
WHAT.
>> Laura: THEY FIGHT TO THE
FINISH.
>> WE GOT A LOT OF FIRST-TIME
CANDIDATES.
>> Laura: TIFFANY SMILEY DID A
GREAT JOB.
>> THERE'S THIS NOTION CANDIDATE
QUALITY.
>> I DO THERE'S AN ISSUE WITH
LEADERSHIP QUALITY.
LIMN QUALITY SEEMS TO BE WHERE
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS FAILING.
MITCH McCONNELL WHO SAYS 7% OF
AMERICAN SUPPORT HIM, HE'S
ROUTINELY THE LEAST POPULAR
NATIONAL POLITICIAN.
HE PICKS WEIRD SIDES TO THINGS.
ONE THINGS HE GOT INVOLVED IN
WAS HELPING LIZ CHENEY THIS YEAR
AFTER SHE WENT TO WAR AGAINST
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
HE DOESN'T SEEM TO --
>> Laura: HE DEFINITELY AGREES S
WITH LIZ CHENEY MORE THAN
AMERICA FIRST POPULISM.
>> LIZ CHENEY HAD A GOOD YEAR
WITH HER MEDDLING IN ELECTIONS.
THIS IS AT ODDS WITH THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> Laura: DO YOU AGREE WITH
MITCH McCONNELL AGREES MORE
WITH LIZ CHENEY ON FOREIGN
POLICY TRADE AND IMMIGRATION?
>> I WOULD JUST SLIGHTLY CORRECT
THAT BECAUSE THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE THEY WERE FORCED
RESIGN OR LOST.
IT'S IN LARGE PART BECAUSE
PEOPLE GOT TIRED OF THAT.
HERE'S SOMETHING I WANT TO SAY.
ANYBODY ASKING JOE BIDEN STEP
ASIDE?
THEY LOVE TELL US WHO OUR
NOMINEE SHOULD BE?
YOU CAN'T HAVE THE SOCIALIST
WOMB, YOU CAN'T HAVE THE
AMERICAN SAMONE.
THEY LIKE TO MEDDLE IN OUR
ELECTIONS BY TELLING US AHEAD OF
TIME WHO OUR NOMINEE SHOULD BE.
>> Laura: THEY LOVE MITT ROMNEY
AND JOHN McCAIN.
NEW YORK WAS THE BRIGHT SPOT FOR
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THAT WAS BECAUSE WE HAD LEE
ZELDIN WHO WENT TO NEW YORK IN
THE LAST WEEKS OF THE CAMPAIGN.
RIGHT INTO THE BELLY OF THE
BEAST.
I WAS LIKE THAT IS THE KIND OF
REPUBLICAN WE NEED TO GO RIGHT
IN THERE AND SAY, THIS IS WHAT I
STAND FOR.
>> HE DID IT AFTER THOSE VOTERS
MOVED TO FLORIDA CONTRIBUTING TO
RON DESANTIS'S HUGE NIGHT.
>> Laura: THEY WANT HIM TO BE
RNC CHIEF.
>> THERE HAS TO BE A FUTURE FOR
PEOPLE LIKE LEE ZELDIN.
HE GETS THE MESSAGE AND THE
MECHANICS.
>> I THINK THE 168 IS IN CHARGE
OF ELECTING HIM
>> Laura: NONE OF THAT MATTER IF
WE DON'T GET THE RESULTS WE
WANT.
>> LEE ZELDIN IS GREAT.
I THINK WE DIDN'T GET SOME OF
THE RESULTS.
PEOPLE BELIEVE THE SUGAR HIGH OF
THOSE PHONY POLLS.
THEY WERE REPUBLICAN LEANING.
EVERYBODY CHERRY PICKED THE
POLLS THEY LIKED.
>> FOR ALL THE VOLUNTEERS WE
HAD, WE DON'T BANK HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF VOTES IN
PENNSYLVANIA WHICH WHAT THEY DID
TO GET FETTERMAN ELECTED.
750,000 EARLY VOTE.
>> WHOEVER IS RUNNING THE RNC,
THEY NEED TO DO THAT IF THEY
WANT TO.
>> Laura: KARI LAKE WENT DOWN
TONIGHT.
DIDN'T WE LEARN?
>> DONALD TRUMP TOLD PEOPLE TO
SHOW UP ON ELECTION DAY.
YOU CANNOT BRING BALLOT ON
ELECTION DAY.
>> YOU CAN'T FIX THESE PROBLEMS
AFTER YOU LOSE.
YOU CAN ONLY FIX THEM AFTER YOU
WIN OR PUT THE TIME IN BEFORE
HAND AND FIX THEM.
>> Laura: WE HAVE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS WHO NEVER DONE
ANYTHING.
WHO DON'T CHANGE CAN THE RULES.
>> BRIAN KEMP DID A GREAT JOB.
TO TRY TO MATCH UP SIGNATURES
AND CURE IT AFTER THE FACT